so the next talk is by Dan Feldman
corsets for thank you also for inviting
me here very excited to be here so I'll
talk about technically they walk for the
last at least 10 years how I applied it
and how it moving from theoretical
computer science and computational
geometry to more applied computer
science and robotics so we still with
defining a bit about talk about we're
talking about real time in Big Data so
big data the usually talk talk about a
huge amount of data from many sensors on
the fly not offline from the floppy
drive and for this we usually need
streaming algorithms that use very
little memory notch so all the memory so
always not store the data in memory you
won't agree with him that walking parlor
without having to debug them as we
usually do it party algorithm so just
use embarrassingly parallel algorithm I
mean kind of totally independent so we
can run totally independent processes we
want simple computations we could use
them with graphical processing units
which are very fast but can compute very
simple operation or even home or fake
encryption which is what we're doing
these days and the stomach would not
want unlike a lot of online algorithms
we don't want to assume things about the
the input of the order of the points
formerly we said that we have infinite
stream vector this is the input and it's
just number of vectors in so far the
memory just poly log N and if you have
em computers for example on the clouds
or mcp use every new point the running
time should be poly log in and should be
a be faster if we have five computers
which will be five times faster now when
we add also the Wilton computation model
to the story this is not enough we
actually also need this value would not
be just awful again it would be actually
few milliseconds so it practice should
be very fast and another thing that we
have a problem with randomized algorithm
so if we have a
a quadcopter drone flying and do it 50
which even with low a probability to a
crash into the wall since you won it 30
times per second it's probably happen
after a few seconds so if they're going
fails with some small probability we
still in trouble so we really preferred
the mystic algorithms and other issue is
debugging randomized algorithm it's
really hard to know whether it is a bug
in the problem or the program or just
one of the failure why aren't the fellow
of the algorithm because you have some
probability of failure I will discuss
this a bit later and general the general
ID with hien cosets is that if we have
large data streaming data on the fly and
algorithm that you already have a
gradient that we happy with we have find
the model we have a logarithm will be
happy with the result the only problem
is that the running time is too slow or
die waiting we just offline so can you
compress the data in some sense we
structure difficult close at sea so
determining the same algorithm on the
court would you do proximately the same
result so how we define exact so
approximately won't proof that this will
be at work with epson approximation lee
one puts epson approximation that the
same up to 1 plus epsilon so its
multiplicative approximation and we
won't also proof in the bound on the
size of the compressions we want to
prove this thread of not just to show
that we have you wasted for this
intuitively there many that the
basically of course just to take some
sample of the input or weighted example
so a lot of very nice properties of
course that I have a lot of story but we
try to just summarize in one minute so
first of all we can solve two is that we
have provable going T's on the
trade-offs unlike you know many other
heuristics secondly we have many np-hard
problems like like a means that are
np-hard but if we just want to reduce
the data you can do this in linear time
the fso compressing the data is
significantly
easier problem in some sense than
solving the problem the nice thing in
practice that we actually have to be
compress the data we just run the
state-of-the-art heuristics on the
compressed data so that's how when you
want to approve a problem in in computer
vision or EEG or in robotics we just
take the favorite heuristics in the
community we just compute causes for
this problem and one you is the
convenience of time on these courses and
beat the state of the art using the
state of that if you come into a company
you're saying that you have an algorithm
that is better than all what all the
engineers did over the last years with
all the fitting to the customer you just
say we just run new algorithm on my
course and that's how it will do better
so there is a lot of very nice also in
the Academy it's make more sense instead
invent new algorithm for community that
does not know you just to just you just
close it for the famous problem they
already solve I will explain how we can
turn very slow offline go atoms into
streaming algorithms and also a greeting
to talk on the cloud in parallel
processes very easy to implement so the
proof sometimes are hundred page of many
quick letters they towed out competition
geometry logical computer science
compressed sensing but algorithm is
usually just 10 lines of MATLAB or
Python code and still the theory is very
deep these days we also apply it on the
on the cloud and the practical system
that you use in the industry like spark
and do exactly fit to the model of
corset of imagine we do that again I
will explain a bit later other thing is
that there is no a single technique for
corset construction so it's not that I
have a technique I just applied for
different problems it's a bit like
approximation algorithms we have some
general techniques but in general for
every problem we need to have a
different corsets an algorithm so that's
why I still have a job and we have so
many papers to write another practical
thing is that a lot of companies tell me
that they had great without using my
corsets for I don't know say k-means and
that's what they do with this call
it's done or did it just run support
vector machine on the course it works
great so we don't understand why but in
practice you can actually use one
corsets to to solve other problems so it
also works very well in practice let's
be a bit more precise of what exactly
the corset so of course it's a bit like
like God know and know exactly what it
is can do only anything if you can they
have the right definition and the number
of definition are very similar to the
number of papers about Constance the
simplest definition is probably this so
you have some input set points lines
chair whatever this is P you have a
status query or half of every four
models we really this is fine it this is
sighs and this is infinite and we have
some cost function sum of distance and
squared distances for every subset of P
to the query q which is positive or
non-negative and now we say that we have
this is epsilon small number between 0
to 1 something like constant not 1 over
N and we say that the subset of P is the
call us at 4p or epsilon causes 4p if
for every query this family the cost
from P to Q is approximated by cause of
the course at Q up to 1 plus minus
epsilon box emission factor here so this
is the subset in general when you talk
about some of course usually talk about
multiplicative wait sometimes we need
additive wait some sometimes it's
actually totally different structure
some expander or some strange other data
structure but essentially we usually
want this property and we when we say
that we can't find a corset using the
executor finishing we just invite invent
another definition the main idea that
this will be small number of bits in
memory in some sense
by what kind of queries into that we
want its general framework p is a stat
and q is a said that's all we know so
well define White was just the
definition I can do whatever I want but
but yeah a few minutes we'll have to be
more precise to actually do something
that will walk so yeah yeah sweater get
the quantification give a lot of
examples first fixed epsilon and then
choose the course yeah so we have we
have endpoints you're going to give me
tomorrow morning another query point and
you ask me what is the sum of squared
distances to the aquarian so where is
the old points in the world the input is
just endpoints the cost of the subject
to the query or cost p to q is the sum
of squared distance for the input points
to the query that will give me two more
and the substance is the course that is
good if you can find a good sub set so
that for every query that you give me
two more I can solve the problem
approximate the cost just using see ya
the question really is ok you have
epsilon matrix C based on epsilon right
yeah since so it's actually the cause
that depend on epsilon and P so it's a
no flow and is it important that the
cost the course it is the same function
as the problem could you for instance
know exactly that's so essentially
that's what I did here right so in some
sense I said C can be any structure of
course also I mean that the cost
function can be whatever you want
actually sometimes it turns out that can
be very assessing compressed sensing
very easy to compress the data but it's
very hard to actually use this solve the
new optimization problem in the
compressed data simple example about
some squared distances the course it is
small then you need to multiply the cost
by some scaling factor yeah usually the
sum of weight is the same is n if
there's in we have n input points
usually expect the sum of weight of the
course that will also be n that's what
usually happens right so so this example
more feet right so that's for some
square we usually need this this this
scenario is most for the farthest point
so if I should they have give the
example tekla father's point and then
you don't need weight given a query just
give me the farthest point from P and
then I want to give away this is the
first course that was about just upset
because it was covering then we have the
more so yeah over there just talk with
people for different fields they
describe me their problem and we try to
have a coarser for this problem
sometimes it's just five minutes because
we reduce the problem to existing
problem sometimes checking a year or two
and most of the problem related to
machine learning usually we do more and
more robotics and more practical stuff
that I will explain a bit later the
intuition why you have usually caused
from machine learning problems is
because in machine learning usually have
a lot of data and you look for very
simple structure very few number of
parameters so in this sense if you're
just looking for a few number of
parameters and you have a lot of model
data intuitive you don't need all the
data you can find a smoke impression
this intuitively actually can perform
allies that using complexities
measurement like visi dimension for
example so let's start with which few
examples and then we get to be to the
more to the theoretical
foundation so example we have a paper
with leggings you came from Tel Aviv
University by waiting for a cleaning
noise denoising image so you have
existent famous algorithm but it works
very good only for low definition image
and offline you want to apply to
high-definition image and also just said
if you have high-definition image or
just dreaming and you don't have time
and we all dont have space to actually
want algorithm on such data you can get
out of memory in matlab just use uniform
random sampling or usually computer
vision is the call it runs ack which is
just you're wasting the sets run the
same algorithm on your for sampling of
the image and will get the same
structure from the image or sure so the
uniform something between sampling the
pixels yeah let's see some examples so
you have a lot of points and just take a
uniform sampling and in this case so
actually yeah sorry in this case you see
for example the image in the left you
take uniform sampling the problem is you
probably take only green points and you
miss the oldest structure of the woman
if you take uni from sampling for the
Mickey Mouse downstair in these things
you probably just get white points so
the problem with which unit from
sampling which is kind of the post forum
popular closets for engineers is that
you usually miss some points that you
cannot get using uniform sample but this
points or maybe the terrorists it's a
for detection it's the the important
picture pixels in the image so it's not
a good idea is a good idea and and
unlike uniform random sampling we can
which you can do in sub linear time as
soon it usually or people from poverty
testing as sometimes do we actually
allowed you to have linear time to
actually scan all the points and
carefully select the points for the
corset so unlike poverty testing you do
have linear time to read all the data
but only one pass you need to select the
right points and that's why we can solve
more problems that for some property
testing which has more constraints
cannot solve
one other surprising thing is that
actually when we run the heuristics on
the corsets usually get better results
on the compression than the original set
so instead of 1 plus epsilon arrow we
get x minus epsilon we don't have formal
explanation but intuitively what the
engineers slain is that if you have some
heuristics sorry ristic that find the
closest local minima with the concert in
some sense you move a lot of points so
the function is also much simpler so
when you find the nearest local minima
dizzam but it's better chance not get
stuck in one of these so intuitively
that's why we get actually better
results on the closet because in some
sense the corset all should do some so
no noisy move on Susie so I'll talk
about how do you do the corset right for
this specific thing yeah so okay i will
give a specific example kossoff robotics
this is the million-dollar question how
you actually do this this is the hard
problem here to each of you kind of
sample the you partition it into a small
patch that's not a jogger item and you
sample the page based on the variance so
if the mean is is green and everything
is green he should you take it with
lower probability but he'll probably get
hi bub this is the bottom line if the of
the paper in the but usually it's more
complicated algorithm so usually what we
do is you do we define some non uniform
be some non even distribution over the
input after one scan then you're kind of
sample points based on this new
distribution we wait so this importance
is called sensitivity which is the
probability to sample the point 0 2 how
important is this point and the way it
is one of the sensitivity so the
expected the value will be good so we
have general theorem to compute corsets
inquiring in general so the first idea
of using this is a divot avoid bottom
line
number and with long but we generalize
it to two more general function set
human language short for k-means problem
so suppose that the cost is just the sum
of distance where distance is
essentially just a positive function
okay exactly what it is not have to be
distance function actually any function
and we define the importance of a point
to be the maximum of all the possible
queries the contribution of the pony
koda query divided by the sum of the
contributions so if you sample for this
distribution so for every point we have
the importance of this point and if you
simply according to this distribution
and you can you could get a call static
and as we defined in the previous slides
and the size of the cost that number of
samples is the VC dimension of Q or
something very related to visit
dimension of the query side divided by
epsilon square which is the arrow size
like Anna Chernov haughton bounds and
this is the sum of orders and sative
ities that you found so I try to explain
what's going on here so this is always
less than 1 because we have a value
divided by sum of value so you can
always bound it by 1 so 1 is always an
upper bound for this value the problem
is then then the sum here will be n
because every point have one sensitivity
so you need to take n points but you
hope that the son of sensitivities will
be small so in general the way that the
intuition behind this definition is the
suppose that was that you have a lot of
points here at one point here and you
want the query is just say one Center so
why this point is important in that in
some sense because there is a single
query query here such that all the
distances zero except this one so this
point have such query such as this is
almost one so it's contributes to all
the costs on the other side each one of
these points you cannot have such a
query so if you put the query here it's
small so all the others and it's the
same where we put the curve so you
cannot find for these points centres
such as they dominated the denominator
the cost that the cost is dominated by
the specific point and that is the
intuition so this is why this point is
important these points are not important
again the definition is very general for
every a proper definition for set P and
Q so why we still need to solve problem
because it's not clear at all how to
bound this value so it's kind of a
reduction use me 10 minutes okay that
summation be over you know so we don't
know p yet so it's p of all the points
so you hope not all the points are
importance with the 10 minutes okay so
in general we expected the monistic
algorithms so for example we will use
deterministic algorithms we don't have
this old style that we have with
sampling algorithms for right
ok good ok so
so want a monistic algorithms because as
explained before we have when we know
robotics we have a problem with
sometimes that going to fail because you
want thousands of times second thing if
you look for this is on one of the paper
when you compare uniform sampling with
non-uniform sampling and deterministic
algorithms you see that although in
general in day infinity deterministic
and the randomized algorithm not quite
the same when you take only very few
number of samples the deterministic
stick exactly the right samples that
centers in this algorithm by the
non-uniform algorithms using all this
concept behind the Chernoff bounds and
everything is quite slow and the
intuition is for example so if you want
to find the clusters in this set of
points and you just do unit from
sampling you will miss this point which
are very important you do non-uniform
sampling you still will sample this
point but after couponing a collector
problem it will take some time still
take a lot of points here until you find
all the points in the deterministic
algorithm we just select this point at
first and only then start select points
from here so you can actually get much
much better bounce on the theoretical
bounds on the on the corset size so the
first application so urgently I decided
I designed the algorithms with me huh
sure you and I most Fiat in my PhD in
Tel Aviv University for improving some
problems in computational geometry and
then in Caltech a walk with low natural
minor bond with the third but I started
to work with people like address crowd
so machine learning more applied
problems and then in MIT my postdoc I
was the only one with a theoretical
background everyone were engineer so we
started to apply to it for problems in
robotics and we'll player world
applications and one of the application
for example where I diary when we get
the GPS data four minutes of people in
China and we want to have too much
thicker summarization of what you are
doing based on the GPS data and so we
can google for example restaurant that I
visited in specific day and get the way
so you can google your life
not just the web and using Yelp you can
find out how much time we spent on each
place at the model that we use is that
we have the GPS data for moving person
this is me in Cambridge what you see in
the graph there is that my XY over time
so we have a signal over time this is
just the map the projection and the main
problem is that all the time you see
that even when I walking on the home or
driving on the road you see that a lot
of knowledge that you want to move four
segments much harder problem is to
cluster all my visit from home to MIT to
cross to all these trajectories to a
single trajectories to a single road so
I know the next I will be working so
it's robotics lab of the NIA because we
started with people and end up with
robots so in a few slides we do the same
for off-track robots so sorry yes do you
have a diary of large number of integers
movements mm-hmm great what what kind of
originally launched so I will just
define it in the next slide so what I
actually interested in compressing the
trajectory to know what the trajectory
with small space so what I saw dr.
ization problem is that you have a lot
of points and you want to approximate it
by a few linear segments for peaceful in
a function in some sense which is the
generalization of linear equation you
want to partition the data into K
interval so each interval will be
approximated by a segment and the
fitting cost is the sum of squared is 9
for each point to the projection the
corresponding intervals and you want to
solve it in real time for streaming data
so a concert for this problem will be
just a weighted subject of points such
that for every query which is case
segment in this case the sum of squared
distance from the original points and
the red points here would be
approximately the same and
and what happened you practice is this
is moving me one of the students moving
and you see that you collect a lot of
points but only few of the points get to
our server and in real time we need to
decide which point to send to the server
and one of the challenge is not only we
want to compress the data but we need to
do it in real time in for streaming data
may be a one of the later we have to do
the same with video so we have a lot of
videos and you want to petition them
into different scenes and one of the
main features this day for courses in
the context of big data and machine
learning is the technique that's
actually very well known in computer
otakon with the science called merging
with use think for the 70s by faxing
button and it'll be the same day the
following thing suppose that you are
just water a Python code matlab corn
fuel lines that know how to compute the
computer core set size 1 over epsilon
for a set of endpoints the running time
is turbo it's offline on your laptop
non-parallel non swimming the claim is
that automatically you can turn it into
a streaming algorithm as i define
streaming in there in their first slides
and on the cloud walking in part on
distributed data using this week store
first of all you take the small state to
over epsilon points and one your
compression algorithm so you get from 12
reps on at one of epsilon but waiting is
slow but since you run it on only on few
number of points to be very fast you do
the same for the next chunk then you
merge them remove the original data and
compress this set so we take the union
of two to corset and compress them again
now we can do this the same for the next
step and compress and EDD and compressed
and then compress the problem is that
the arrow will be larger so we want to
push absent to the end because get lot
so we don't want to do this instead we
actually don't you take the union of
distant the corset there we take the
union of this to uncompress them
and then we do Chi her kind of a binary
tree and in the morning we have cost for
all the data in every given moment we
have at most log and cosseted memory
because each level has only single
corset and the only thing that we had to
compute you know if a given moment is a
corset for two of epsilon points so the
only things like we don't always have to
run on small number of points and in the
morning we just want our you istic work
the exhaustive search algorithm on the
small data but you need your up slops
yeah yeah episodes this in one is
usually half of something or so usually
I mean one post epsilon to the n 4 knots
or small epsilon is 1 plus epsilon log N
and Absolut's to constant if I remember
I think epsilon less than some small
concise still hold from cockaboose 1.1
to the login yeah it's to be less than 1
you right can't be too weak tube but for
it has to be less than a constant lesson
constant but not less than 10 right yeah
yeah yeah there is an upper bound yeah
definitely wear but epsilon again it's
not one of rain but it's less than some
constant again in practice we don't
really have epsilon in the code in
practice what we said you have 200
points we turn the best handle points
that's it so this is just for the ferry
anyway in the fairway don't care about
this constant when you reduce paper in
practices just to 100 100 and again when
we put epsilon equal hundred usually get
epsilon equal 0.001 and all the epsilon
delta ganna just from the fairing
practice you just have 200 points and
you want 100 point that's also we don't
worry too much about constant so this is
for you see how the memory get filled
over time it's really a logarithmic as
the pranic step Arthur we promised us
all these jumps up because of the
structure of the tweet so this is sighs
we put this is memory and now if you
want to 180 powder it's also very easy
so we can just send each closer to a
different computer and
the Union and do this for each level Oh
what might be a better for infinite
stream if we have for example two
computers just give the even samples to
one computer the odds and put the stove
the first computer each one will have
its own tree and again in every second
or if we're in the morning you can
collect the root of these trees from
each computer and again also notice the
communications is extremely small here
because you just need to community the
course it's not all the data okay so now
to robotics so in MIT labs they use this
huge very expensive quadcopters with a
lot of sensors and it can only use them
when we're under on the lab and their
special room in the lab and you need to
have a helmet because it's extremely
dangerous one of the students also cut
his finger because of these guys and I
said I when I came to Israel I really
want to do we face if we want to do
practical thing I wanted really to be
practical at home and not with with
masks so so the problem is not only the
cost this is a very few thousand two
dollar for such a robot there are really
a very very unsaved illegal most in
Israel on us so instead we have
interwebs hundreds of this kind of robot
so this is you can just buy them on
Amazon twenty dollars usually the pole
they don't have really a sensors on them
as we need to hide the protocol but the
night and the good thing is that if you
don't have sense or just someone camera
you have a very nice theoretical problem
is that you can start to solve with not
too many parameters so this is some you
would
yeah GPS denied you know that I don't
have also computer even well then
because they're so small so I should
have bought something but it's more for
the car for the drones again every
students gifted want to play wit at home
if you go to the force you see a lot of
them on the trees near the University
and and it's very actually you know if
the I won that huge quadcopters equation
the war they are broken this this guy
just a piece of plastic so actually it's
very hard to break it when you just
throw it on the wall and if we also it's
very easy to fix it so it's really
really practical for research and for
for teaching and get the main challenge
and make it actually i have actually
have control it without sensor so we
have to approve the first approach to
put some reflective markers on the
quadcopters it was just like a market
with specific color so using infrared
cameras we detect this point and follow
the drone and we use for this a very
popular systems como cheap motion
capture system we are specifically you
stop the truck this is a very expensive
system which set infrared cameras they
just rock the object and tell you where
it is so for example to use it for games
just to get the intuition of how it
works
you see they have all these markers on
them and use it for this is for game
fighting in Sony so essentially it's
your fav in complicated animation to
just record the people and
yeah so you see the essentially played
the the movie and using the using the
figures they are they turn it into
animation but this system is really
really expensive and we try to have to
do the same thing we just just a very
simple
so each such commodities all-in cost six
thousand six thousand dollars and
because although a Gutenberg inside it's
really expensive hardware the problem
that we actually want a cheap system so
what we use is this sony camera from
playstation 3 just five dollar on amazon
and the idea is to have better
algorithms so the harder is Vicki but
the algorithm will be much stronger so
that's how we compete with the with
hardware so we start to learn what
arguing and actually this camera try to
solve so this is the problem so
essentially to know where you are like
if you look at the north pole star and
you based on the location of the style
you know where you are so in general the
inputs is their end points the end
markets that you put on there on the
robotic quadcopters and in real time you
see a specific set of points and you try
to understand what was the translation
and rotation for the original set to the
set that you see to understand the new
position orientation of the object so if
you just translation then it easy then
you know that observe certain just the
original set plus I'm translation vector
and it's very easy to compute this
vector but practically usually have a
lot of noise because the resolution of
the cameras you have few frames per
seconds you have delay until you get the
image and also communication problems so
you have some error and actually this is
not exact so you have many okay so we
want to solve this optimization problem
minimize Samba spread business for
example for each point to its
corresponding point so this you want to
find the vector till to minimize some of
strengths where distances from each
point with the translate often first
nation to its corresponding point Qi and
when you also have rotation it's mean
that not only doublet moves but you also
rotate
and now the rotation is just a Qi is
just mean the original point x tation
matrix plus influence the translation
vector and now you want to select
rotation translation and now again you
want to find translation and rotation it
will minimize the sum of squared
distance for the translator the note 8
points to the episode points and the
main result is actually a determined to
show now is that we can always find a
small course that's more subset of this
point so that if we solve the problem
only on the small subset of this world
point if you're talking about points in
our d we can get the same solution as we
review f a severe we have solved the
problem the original set and the main
idea is this so to solve the
optimization problem it's very easy you
just compute the SVD so p is the
original set and by d q is the observed
set you just compute the SVD and these
two matrices to Otto Graham matrices the
multiplication give you the rotation
matrix that you want so we only problem
if we need to compute this in real time
another problem is that we usually don't
know actually which point in the
original data go to which point in the
observed set so not only want to
minimize the sum of squared distance you
also need from all the permutation of
the point to decide which point should
go to which or third point now which
makes things much much harder so so they
the way that we find call set for this
problem for the post estimation problem
is a weighted vector whose weight vector
whose most entries are 0 and for every
rotation matrix our translation vector T
some squared distance for their original
point in the observation is the same as
the weighted sum of just few sub small
subset of this purple point and in real
time instead of following all tracking
all the points we just track the coset
it's how we can solve all this hard
problem very hard for recruiting the
permutation problem
in real time so just give the main idea
how we do essentially choose this corset
so we we essentially we've showed that
if you have the SVD you just need to
find a diagonal matrix with this end
exes WI such that the SVD of WP + WQ
which is the weighted set of points will
be the same as the original set with us
this video of the original set and then
we it's easy to show it to see the top
optimal solution is essentially the same
so essentially reduce the problem to the
the Performing problem we have n vectors
like this you just want to give a
proxima infest approximation to the sum
of these vectors and again we stefaned
yesterday yesterday we only have we need
that without waiting will do very fast
operation like much of supplication and
that's all and this problem can we just
solve using the car toward or a theorem
essentially so if you have points which
is thus a mean of this point you can
always find a d plus 1 points that will
give you the exact so to compute the
convex combination of only three points
will give you the exact point and for
jenny's walk for general dimensional
space and when there is very high when
we talk with computer vision usually and
we use the visual feature which very
high dimensional space with an
approximate the version that ask that
you find something that you that is very
close to the mean but use number of
pointed in the independent of D only on
the error and I'll going team is
essential you just pick a point pick the
farthest point this is the first point
in the closet pick the farthest point
for the mean project the original mean
on this linear combination and continued
for the new mean just take the farthest
point take the projection on this line
and the claim is that in every iteration
we get smaller and smaller error so
citizens don't have too much time i will
try to show you some movie how it works
in practice
so this is work with two of my students
only Nasser and I bearing to run and so
we just move by the robot from amazon
cloud we hack the protocol so we can be
as the algorithm we can control the the
drone instead of if the remote control I
can see in the image and next thing this
is the system we just used to very cheap
camera to Internet of Things board with
just the last by PI if you know it is
very small and cheap computers we took
put the markers on the drones what we'll
see in the next image is that we
compared the system on the million
dollar this is the million-dollar system
in the lab this is the week cameras with
our algorithm with the corset and this
is unit for using only from random
sampling so we do a lot of repeated the
trials and we actually see that using
week harder better algorithms you can
get very similar algorithms to the to
the very expensive system with a very
weak algorithms and later we did the
same with instead of to have action or
two numbers drawn without cameras around
this is the random sampling and
the next thing is actually to have two
numbers don't we actually need visual
feature without markers for example look
for localized yourself using points on
the ground so now it's tough Marcus we
just have a visual feature on the robot
and we just tracked specific point then
did we find interesting on the image and
compute causes for this point so now you
don't have markers just visual feature
from the algorithms that you find in the
image and this is tiff features go in
computer vision and the green point on
the corsets that we and we round out the
organization algorithm only on the new
corset and every moment and there are
many objects so this guy's just hoping
so if you solve the whole problem you've
done because because if you know how to
have we can do you just send it to every
given other point so this is the main if
you solve this problem we solve any
other problem and
the
if you if you just use the same cost of
the time we see that it's become to be
like uniform sampling so actually every
to a swift frame we compute new corset
because actually take more time to just
one frame so we keep tracking the seam
of the same course that for the next two
frames and then compute new course
that's how we deal with the real time
problem of commutation there are many
other open problems there for example
now try to find the data problem which
what happened which we have many quads
so in this case we have that kind of
hard matching problem and class doing so
the existing system we just tried to
cluster all these robots but he confused
which point belong to which quadcopters
so you have beautiful clustering
problems in real time that we that we
had to solve one of the day because
their camera lose it I mean when you
cummin are confused so if just don't
talk waiting for 1 1 millisecond we just
go like this and again when we talk
about these guys from the actually a run
Berkeley the company that built this
system we actually talk with them about
the algorithm they will use very naive
algorithms so using our algorithm is
very easy to better algorithm it's very
easy to compete with them it sure that
you can do much better and now the
intent to actually implement our GUI
thermal on their hardware so to boost
the running time because now everything
one on the laptop going with laptop so
it's extremely slow and they use the
embedded system and everything is one on
the camera itself ok I'm running out of
time so we just converge
so we're doing this day so cozy for deep
learning is very popular until until
they're the path of deep learning will
disappear we will have causes for deep
learning we hope so also walking this do
cross for decision trees more
application for robotics for example
what if you have gps data and gyro data
and maybe texted and understand so how
you combine this sensor you have very
interesting optimization problems there
apple announced too few weeks ago that
they're moving to differential privacy
so we have a paper about differential
private cosa that show surprisingly how
compression cause that related to
privacy and we want to have a greeting
for higher dimensional spaces and for
more problems which off the ghost buster
and then the other words we now work to
implement kosovo morphic encryption that
is that extremely slow but on the course
that will be much much faster so we have
a chance and especially if we have about
100 computers on the cloud we show that
you can actually solve machine learning
problem using homomorphic encryption and
we also again a lot of people ask for
implementation because it's very hard to
with the papers but it's very easy to be
the code so we now have I try to have a
general open library and spark that
implement all this course that and we
hope to publish it and next month it's
all I think I'd be happy to talk with
you about your power and maybe you can
find courses for your problems so feel
free that's how most of the paper
started like thank you very much quick
what the distance cameras over the drone
g cameras me right right so the good
news is that you know the very expensive
cameras use a better lens so the
distance father but it turned out that
it's better to have more eyes than stone
your eyes so if you have very many cheap
cameras much much better than just two
very strong cameras yeah so so currently
what we have all the into all the
bidding of university many of these
cameras the next step is of course to
get rid of them and just put one camera
on the drone it's very very hard because
again we don't have computer on the
drones we just use a little camera but
this is will be the the next step of the
system to just have one camera on the
drone well Carter we just spread many of
these camera again the extremely cheap
so we can use a lot of them No so this
is another thing we have it's just about
10 minutes or something but we have
charging station to adjust from when
after five minutes you just replace with
that other guy that's how we have 24
hours on the clock and again it's the
students did is that I don't have it
here but just really really simple piece
of metal we just turn on it and place
between them more questions
it is thank you very much